nope nope nope nope
you go sister you tell him you tell a
question yeah yeah
which one of you [ __ ] did it
that means they must be Pokey wait I no
no no I just did a task with him on the
left
[Music]
I forgot the most important acid my hair
is wet you get to watch it get dry
during this live stream
oh okay you guys prefer elbow can't oh
sorry I forgot I'm not allowed to look
at chai
just get a bit boring you know
and it just got a lot boring here all
right now we can look at chat
she really did it oh no I saw him in the
admin room
thank you James thank you I don't know
what happened are you kidding kill me
laughing room that is toes you did and
where did it what happened where'd you
go I ran to the north side when lights
were called I'm not the Imposter
so can somebody stupid Discord keybind
thing it keeps like it's not actually
staying on
okay
um so are you using push to mute or yeah
oh toggle me is what I need huh yeah
that's what people use period thanks
guys
yeah see how easy that was oh look at my
bad bad
Jake
wait what about James again
[Applause]
a few times in a row
we're getting faster
and then y'all see and he has the
audacity to vote corpse Jesus Christ
or three times in a row like watch that
don't rub it in James why does my thumb
looks like a dick I never realized this
is [ __ ] up if anyone just joined a
stream I apologize
it's right outside of Kim's really yep I
actually don't think it's Charlie even
though he found the body well yeah we
can pretty much Clear me because I
reported that second kill but there'd be
no reason for me to tell you guys where
that second one was if I was the
Imposter so it's not Pokey or Jack I'm
assuming
um
little frilly butt what needed you're on
muted Felix oh
between me right I wanna clear Charlie
just because I've been with him alone so
many times and he hasn't snapped my neck
off but I can't say that's a hundred
percent sure was I muted that whole time
[ __ ] yeah yeah my God I was
with Charlie right behind him I hooked
up with him I'm pretty sure she did Med
Bay okay so for me I would be suspicious
of me too
wait why a second no no reason
no
I'll change it
okay this one is good
um
how does this keep happening
[Music]
I was like next to you at security
it came down
Felix no I didn't see it they're getting
ready behind me what is you said you're
on your way into lights it's like
between security and lights then it must
have happened on my way there yeah I was
on the cameras like this whole time no
no can anyone see that they are on to
make sure that he is on them
I'm voting to skip I don't know who it
is I didn't see it I don't want to just
let it ride and see what happens oh my
God I almost died I almost died that was
pretty close flash speed I'm gonna get
him right as he sends it
oh
I'm gonna do my tasks this was this was
just getting kind of embarrassing uh
what what's the plan yeah are we done
with our task guys I'm all done with
tasks yeah I'm done as well same I'm
waiting on the ghosties
um so I guess we oh I see what's
happening the ghosts want us to vote
someone off here yeah okay so this is
this is my thoughts I think it's
probably Pokey here since she wasn't
super gung-ho on saikuna when Sean and I
didn't vote you don't let him get away
with murder just because he sounds cute
100
now because it wasn't me
I'm so sorry Pokey yeah that's why I
started thinking corpse was innocent
because all right good game Instagram
James Charles he's Anderson of course
all right a respectable time on the card
swipe
oh my God guys
you're embarrassing yourself
not a fan of this one
oh wait what the [ __ ] happened there the
body on the southern trash compactor oh
okay oh wait so who left electrical
first then because it was me toast it's
not me I'm in weapons currently doing my
shooting thingies where you have to
shoot the asteroids it was toast me and
Dave right and that was someone else I
was in there before everyone I thought I
fixed the lights but then they got well
left at the same time there was four I
left before I went over to electrical
and pretty sure literally almost every
single person was in there you left I I
left which I left for you guys you guys
went down I went up and then I came down
to see if someone was going to do bottom
trash to finish it off but yeah
everyone's in there the point is that a
couple of people left early that's the
key to the mystery okay
because Charlie wasn't there Charlie
checked on me on cam so I yeah but that
was after lights he's talking about from
lights oh okay Felix was with me for a
little bit and did not murder me I will
say that
I wouldn't marry you even if I was
impossible okay good quiet
[Music]
up what oh it wasn't me
um
I believe him I believe
um what happened what that's all you
gotta say
oh oh no Rey's dead
whoa cause it was enough for toast
apparently
[Music]
it was just right above medical I saw
Pokey walking but I think it was
drive-bye
sworn I just like right on the edge of
my bubble uh my sight bubble I see
someone running I think it was a
drive-by based on the way Pokey was
moving so
what'd you guys see exactly
um Pokey came into medical and then I'm
not gonna lie I actually don't think
it's saikuno because I came into medgay
and he was out skinny and I don't think
he would scan alone
unless I don't know I saw Pokey walk in
I looked like yeah figured I just wanted
to wait for him and then and then and
then we both walked out and found a body
in that hallway yep and you don't think
it's right it could be Pokey but the way
she was acting like she looked just as
confused where did you come from
where I saw someone running though like
it could have been okay
I thought that came from below my memory
tell me here but I actually I think I
Came From Below not from up you came
from Top engine into us and then reactor
was called okay yes
I think I saw the person there must be
someone upper but you said it was with
you guys
I figured maybe we could do process of
elimination
on the right side of the map not near
anybody the entire time so I have no
helpful information so far I assess the
hardest yeah and oh
nope nope nope nope
you go sister you tell him okay you tell
a question yeah yeah
who's dead which one of you
[ __ ] did it that means they
must be Pokey wait I know
it's with him on the left and then a
group of us were together I think toast
and Jack were there and O2 was called I
met up with corpse I don't think it was
corpse either I think it's
like that like the O2 is out for example
like there's as does um and you have to
go like this is oh my God and you have
to go Jesus you have to go to the
specific location to like fix it or
whatever
you know how there's like a few
different locations there's two yeah two
multiple people yeah places have to be
fixed before it all gets fixed yes yeah
one person can do both yes or no okay
wait I have been with someone this
entire round it is not me and it can be
proven for at the beginning I was with
toast and Jack and me and saikuno did
the same task in reactor toast do you
remember we met up with corpse when O2
was called
yeah the last place I saw and then
bought oxygen so yes and me and corpse
were alone we did O2 together he didn't
kill me all the way down and then I met
up with James this was not us
I also says Jack I appreciate that thank
you how many tasks in medical is she
gonna do
seriously everyone leave everyone leave
when I'm [ __ ] which one is this oh
Jack don't kill me
all right maybe it isn't that
James Charles is dead this is what I was
thinking we were all in a group except
for Pokey and corpse and that taskbar
never moved when we weren't doing tasks
corpse came from the body two rounds ago
and had no idea where he came from with
like Amnesia and it's like yeah
I actually forgot I actually have a
really bad memory but I wasn't James
with us in weapons yeah but that was
like the task part didn't we all just
get trapped in electrical except host
and James
here's the reason why they close
with the button accudency James when was
this place we saw him uh weapons right
yeah yeah for someone killing that stack
as we left yeah probably you guys think
it might be Jack now Jack was Jack was
first away from that stack
what tasks did you do last round corpse
first
my memory man
um do not say who you voted for why not
I think you're innocent because if you
say it that imposters are gonna die I
think one of them's jackets he didn't do
second part of trash and he didn't
upload the first part I was with you and
Charlie the entire time
am I Wrong Am I Wrong I think you I
honestly think you're wrong I think it's
corpse
you told me not to tell you said nothing
you know
I did I did
Ah that's my podcast
[Music]
I wanted to vote
sorry team just got back so I have to go
for a few meetings I'm so sorry to leave
you like this
yeah
you're famous
[Laughter]
over YouTube gang yeah twitch
sucks with their mid-rolls yeah we're
not gonna watch your Amazon show [ __ ]
purple that's oh wait your purple day
sorry uh
YouTube
hey twitch more like what a [ __ ] yeah
yeah
hey twitch check this
that's what I think of you oh [ __ ]
uh he really did that though ah dude we
do what are you guys doing nothing
missing twitch twitch
it's only funnier
foreign
[Applause]
called yourself imposter
yeah I wanted to try something new see
if it works
all caps
is something two getting imposter like
corpse gets it more yeah I wanted to go
to my last round just for that sake and
I was mad that's unbelievable
can you say hey son I'm really proud of
you
I I don't know what that sounds like
oh oh no
where the body at oh God oh my God I
just came up on a body too I think it's
the same one it's outside of vitals
right uh no I mine was uh the weapons
room
um oh well there's also a body outside
of vitals does anyone know how Reese or
old these might be I checked vitals kind
of early and there was nothing dead
there so I think one of them was at
least recent rent okay uh Ray what was
your path thing Miss Ram I did the
weather node and then I did the node Ken
has done like 20 million tasks and
toasted the very first one yeah I'm
speeder in the stuff Ken can you hear a
pokey uh they were with me no one died
yeah yeah
so this was I I don't know if it was a
double though could have just been one
person I thought you said you found one
body by vitals right yes but I think
there's enough time for it to be two so
I'm saying I can't for sure clear Pewds
no you can you were with me does anyone
have Med Bay he didn't do these kills I
just mean like but I I can't think of me
then because I was a weekend before that
before you came along what the hell no
one's Sesame this entire game and now
someone does it I'm like what
hahaha
I don't know what that was but it was
that lights and I just saw Charlie kill
him
so I don't know who it was it was me
just like you know I didn't see the
other person but it was a stack kill so
you saw him do it sakuna it was not a he
just killed here's what I think happened
Charlie and Jack were both there Charlie
randomly killed in front of me so my
theory would be it was a failed double
kill Maybe
[Music]
wait who else was there Charlie and Jack
and who else oh the person yeah
[Music]
that makes sense let's get Charlie first
so much I'll vote on seven
carbs can you can you say Speed Run for
me
[Music]
yeah Charlie first yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
[Music]
that's my new ringtone look at the
Shroud sub sound
[Music]
Speed Run Speed Run Speed Run
no I was going to say last time that I
was in my map and I didn't even know
what happened
he missed the double kill because he had
a sabotage up oh
no
the first round I went with corpse I
stuck on his ass we I guess we left
Charlie with Dave it's that time down at
the bottom of weapons I went up with him
it is possible you know maybe Charlie
just misclicked Speed Run no
okay peace
it's possible wait Jack you voted for
yourself whatever man dude because the
same thing has happened to me before
I've also had my map up
[Applause]
you were so clean I let you down
what what I was gonna leave oh oh yeah
oh okay
I mean someone got booted anyways I got
disconnected oh that's fine I was an
imposter
oh
nice
all the best guys thanks for all the new
members appreciate you guys y'all have a
tootsie whatever that means I see you
take care
ah
this is the only time that we'll have
like a private conversation when the
lights went off the second time Charlie
was just sitting in the middle of the
hallway doing nothing and he didn't
really run to them yeah I was waiting to
see if Sean was going to kill toast
because toast did like some really risky
electrical test in the top of there
why would I kill him when I don't have
that ability Charlie
I'm wondering
a girl
um
he's
he's
dead no no
I think I'm the highest level in the
entire game I'm level 27 and I stopped
playing like what eight a year ago I'm
dissing her what's that under your bed
uh probably a uh a guitar
probably yeah
okay not wholesome
can someone else die can someone else
die please now we know she's a bad liar
at least
this feels like a dream like I finally
get to confront him about it it's been
years don't watch it don't watch it
[Music]
people out to make it easier and now
he's throwing the phone I'm literally
just saying what happened it's a
tambourine
packed
[Music]
[Music]